é bom dia sou eu sou arquiteto e quando
terminei o curso para resolver um
trabalho que eu tenho começado estava
complicado e que pedir imenso da
iluminação natural etc
eu vou onde shopping e ligava a
iluminação natural e ao contrário do que
estava à espera em vez de falar de
iluminação natural com solado impacto
ambiental está nos primórdios em 1994
uma coisa que o impacto ambiental edson
e coisas que eu assinava muito ã frica
ambientalistas pessoas formadas fato e
gravata falar em números
e de uma coisa que eu então adoro a
arquitetura é uma paixão na realidade
era responsável por cerca de 50% dos
impactos ambientais do planeta em facto
direta e indiretamente arquitetura uma
vez que também é criador ea história dos
temas humanos não é
estamos aqui dentro de edifícios vamos
viver 80% da nossa vida dentro do
edifício
isso quer dizer que este grande
paradigma
cerca de 90% planeta à custa do défice
tal responsabilidade direta da
arquitetura
neste momento podemos dizer que o
planeta está completamente
artificializada é impossível nós
pensarmos que a natureza no sentido
natureza selvagem
continua a existir um ser humano neste
momento já entrou direto também ou
indiretamente sobre a natureza tem tudo
a partir de agora passa a ser oficial e
esse é um dos grandes nas grandes
complexidades do momento é uma coisa
absolutamente nova história da
humanidade nunca aconteceu tal coisa
havia problemas de escala questões de
escala mas aí a nível global mudar o e
este registo foi uma coisa com esta
magnitude nunca tinha acontecido e desde
logo a cidade é uma das grandes
responsáveis por essa mudança
mas também é uma das soluções porque a
cidade simultaneamente sendo
o o um sítio onde se acumulam pessoas
não concentram acumulam as pessoas é
simultaneamente também um grande
transformador da cidade não cria nem
realidade transforma e se durante é até
a industrialização em grande parte de
transição é esse dado era ela também
criadora de energia porque tinha espaços
rurais - eu saio muito próximos e que
sustentavam neste momento a cidade
recusa a natureza é higiênica é estéreo
está completamente parada é a sociedade
da natureza e essa exploração é uma das
coisas também
o homem se tiver que optar por qualquer
uma destas funções nunca vai optar pela
natureza vai estar sempre possível com o
seu próximo
mas há aqui uma questão tão importante é
que agora para para optarmos por banco
com o próximo com o próximo também temos
que optar por natureza e desde logo esta
questão da cidade levando uma questão
importante é a natureza deixou de ser
também um objeto do nosso foco na nossa
moldura concentração
isso porque porque vivemos rodeados
seres humanos é natureza deixou de
servir como exemplo pra nós vimos no
campo e vemos uma coisa qualquer porque
vemos seres humanos estamos a começar a
transformar os seres humanos ea
trabalhar científicamente sobre os seres
humanos
ia mudar a natureza é trabalhando também
para o nosso e 3 próprio isso é uma
espécie de design total não é isso são
as coisas que nos vão se também para
depois o nosso trabalho e resolvendo a
tentar resolver e outro grande parede do
outro grande outra grande dae outro
grande foco da sociedade atual é que
esta linha e dar esta irresponsabilidade
de certo modo mas simultaneamente
incapacidade de gerir um sistema
complexo neste momento através daquilo
que ele está atrás nós temos já hoje
capacidade
começar a gerir sistemas mais complexos
do que nós tínhamos e daí surgir uma
idéia que neste momento é homem frame é
o grande grande questão que o que vai
gerir esta esta mudança dos resíduos
para recurso
xandão um ciclo este ciclo antigamente
era uma espiral e neste momento nós
estamos a fechar o tema central ea criar
facto uma tentativa de ir resolvendo é é
nossa necessidade do curso está uma
imagem que é o primeiro disco digital
foi feito a andar em alguns e facto
existiu pá e eu já seja ainda pelo
infinito não é e nós conhecemos mais o
infinito do que nos conhecíamos a nós
próprios e este regresso este concerto a
concentração na ciência da casa que é um
sentido a ecologia é um grande foco
neste momento o nosso trabalho tem
integração sistêmica no habitar na casa
nesta moldura que está à volta do ser
humano que é simultaneamente um
desencanto porque é casa é também ela
própria neste momento é grande
exportadora destas do desses dois temas
do sistema da sociedade e da natureza eo
nosso processo e brilhos este sistema
tentar criar soluções para que os
abrindo e para que os simultaneamente vá
entre frio o mínimo possível através de
um fluxo circular de materiais de
aumentos de documentos naturais da
energia do da água e do curso procurar
que o sistema tenha o mínimo impacto
possível né no externo
então eu não sei é um processo complexo
na abertura e simultaneamente um
encerramento digamos deste processo
maneira que é o impacto enorme
envolvendo hora a uma uma grande grande
palavra de ordem digamos do fim da
modernidade do arquiteto princípios da
casa da música do porto aos seus mal me
vendo
e esse lazio sentido expansão nós
estamos neste momento espontâneo não é
intencional numa grande
o samba bairro não tem nada a ver com
isso é uma realidade no nosso cotidiano
de trabalho
temos vindo a trabalhar cada vez melhor
em cada vez as casas mais pequenas
esse é um trabalho que está pronto o
trabalho está pronto é que que vai vir a
ser construído e facto temos aqui um
sistema humano e uma tentativa de
resolver um sistema humano de tal forma
circular
estas estruturas que estão a ver suas
estruturas dos clientes do total que
podem estar pronto preparado show pra
expectante soltar no espaço num barco
que seja é e que servem de suporte é uma
arquitetura um espaço vai sendo mais
ligeiro de construção mais ligeira mas a
idéia é que o centro vai sendo justa
postiva china é é um módulo em sistemas
possível de energia no petróleo é
sistemas ativos neste caso painéis
solares fotovoltaicos ou térmicos
carreira pode ser toda aquela cobertura
e este sistema pretendo trabalhar a
questão da arquitetura já introduzindo o
tal processo é em que o carro a
comunicação ea casa se reúnem num único
sistema
eu eu eu trabalho a paisagem não é pode
viajar pela paisagem pode existir para
além da cidade
tal questão da expansão do do ser humano
do planeta é entretanto relativamente ao
funcionamento neste momento a
arquitetura tem que comprovar não só
desenhar ou fazer coisas bonitas
pensamos ter conseguido também mas
simultaneamente comprovar o seu
funcionamento e as ferramentas de
comprovação começam a ser parte do nosso
trabalho cotidiano
nós não só fazemos os designers com
comprovamos o
temos através de ferramentas de
simulação e que nos possibilitam é ver
como é que as coisas funcionam e
trabalhando os resultados maneira
ajustar o resultado final
este projecto é um projecto que o que o
teu o é para ser um dia e aproximando a
rua e e facto lembrando que fazer isto
quero trabalhar na janela maneira que
ela pudesse facto abrir mais um sistema
e consegue desenvolver a comicidade
domínio está um protótipo um resultado
já a final mas muito foi um processo
muito demorado e trabalhado de
investigação e desenvolvimento e que
resultou no final num prémio bes
inovação a janela é um é uma coisa
simples junção de uma série de técnicas
algumas ancestrais mas na realidade
junta desta forma e e num objecto
standard pronta ser aplicado e como ter
goku e tentativamente procurar é r
utilização e regeneração do edifício já
existente é é uma novidade e é
considerada uma invenção até este foi o
momento eureka portanto é que isso
funciona quase como um ar condicionado
natural não vou perder muito mais tempo
é porta no final do dia depois do sol é
concentrar em dia num momento acumulador
no final do dia esta porta que é
simultaneamente foi toda faixa e
preserva a energia e através de um
fenômeno físico que a inércia térmica
essa energia quando as pessoas chegam a
casa é ter distribuído para o espaço é
para dar alguma das índias no valor de
forma que nós ainda conseguimos acumular
ele é um cara primário nunca permitido
tanto nós tivemos que utilizar que o
sistema ativo para dar um boost para que
o funcionário um pouco melhor mas que
funciona como é k em alturas do do
trecho e horário em geral
é metade do preço é preciso quitar o
funcionamento da janela
o refletor durante o dia vai vai
permitindo uma comoção em uma
concentração de energia e da radiação
solar em formas de energia
antes no fim do dia isola completamente
o sistema isto é importantíssimo para
garantir depois que haja este fluxo da
do calor digamos nesta troca pelo pai
entre o espaço mais uma vez foi um
trabalho muito ensaio muito
entusiasmante com um grupo fantástico da
universidade em dois anos o tratamento
física das construções pessoas brancas e
uma nova moeda com quem trabalhamos
agora também no desenvolvimento do
trabalho
do outro o do outras idéias e dos
constantes
eu tenho até eu teve já uma pretensão no
edifício em leiria é em que extraem
engraçado nós vimos tantas janelas mesmo
cerca de 200 janelas em vários sítios do
de em braga guimarães aqui no porto e
quando formos aplicar este difícil eu só
tinha é a ideia era preservar só os
pilares e quando vamos aplicar a janela
dava três centímetros de diferença em
uma das páginas dos pilares em que não
provoque facto um grande um desmatamento
e uma em um trabalho exaustivo de z
procura de dimensionamento isto é um
trabalho que está a desenvolver em que
vai ser em razão do meu tormento
é uma forma que encontrei não vou
desenvolver muito porque não está ainda
estava acontecendo mas é uma forma que
encontrei de as pessoas conseguirem
comunicar com o espaço
nós introduzimos os dados biométricos e
dados fisiológicos num determinado mas
eu não ligo
vamos conseguir que que o espaço
responda é principalmente as questões
ligadas ao conforto e à climatização
trabalham essencialmente por ser um
sistema estatístico tem empate com o
site porque neste momento estamos aqui
só acho que somos 300
se tivesse um saem o sistema está a
funcionar da mesma forma tanto se eu
souber que estão aqui 300 pessoas têm é
que nós somos eo que estamos a
necessitar
em termos de conforto térmico e altri
uma resposta completamente diferente
provavelmente seria poupar muito disse
mazin e agora uma outra que está a ser
apadrinhada por um laboratório
estrangeiro e que está em volta a
começar seria desenvolvida ainda não
sabemos bem escala mas a minha esperança
é que se conseguirá nos call
isso porque porque é trabalhar uma
escala mais pequena
incitamos - mas menos intensidade
energética para criar as coisas e eu
entendo uma coisa muito simples é uma
turma tropia isto é uma reciclagem de
uma ideia da janela
nós quando começamos a janela começamos
com os brancos tornem de de abrir e com
sites etc
fizemos dezenas de vídeos destes
literalmente centenas de vídeos textos e
agora vamos buscando estes resíduos e às
vezes inspirados por novas idéias e esta
é uma delas é essa troca de impressões
com está o laboratório pode prever-se
hipóteses já nestas destas designers que
estão por vencer microcélulas solares
têm exatamente desta forma o
estranhamento foi não foi intencional ea
capacidade de se não houvesse rompimento
que está a ver com os primeiros mas
suárez abrir não é como uma flor como as
pétalas
é parece bastante interessante porque
depois à noite faça tudo passivo nas
máquinas e os protestos começaram a
falar um pouco mais finas e tal mas eu
francamente acho que vai era dos
extremos da escala conseguimos com a
pouca intensidade que não conseguimos
trabalhar a nível dos raios solares
conseguimos que é o que eu digo que esse
sistema funciona um pouco como o papel
com este sistema vivo que está que é
reagir ao sol é fingir envolvendo região
maio
saem grande artificialidade ao mesmo
tempo que eu acredito que estamos a
viver um mundo artificial
eu julgo que a expulsão agora de
isopores mundo
merece mundo é procurar soluções que
pelo menos tenham em conta é que o que
nós vamos respeitar e que destruímos que
a natureza da bahia